when most people think about The
Sopranos they think about that ambiguous
ending people are still discussing the
final shot to this day but over a decade
later we think we finally understand the
ending of The Sopranos probably
hopefully maybe well let's break it all
down one of the most important
relationships in The Sopranos if not the
most important relationship is between
mob boss Tony Soprano and his therapist
dr. Jennifer Melfi for years the two
danced around each other in melfi's
office as a therapist was often
entranced and sometimes repulsed by
Tony's gangster ways making things even
more complicated Tony was sometimes in
love and sometimes sick of his therapist
through it all the personal and
professional connection very nearly
ended on more than one occasion but the
two always seemed to find their way back
to each other then in the penultimate
episode of the series Melfi comes to a
realization after a colleague encourages
her to read up on how Tony as a
sociopath might simply be taking
advantage of her convinced a he's been
using her Melfi cuts Tony off during a
tense final session after that Tony
doesn't attempt a call or contact her
and as far as we know he considers their
relationship over just as he does
remember this it'll be important later
loose ends an uncertain fates are a
hallmark of The Sopranos final season
and nowhere is that more devastatingly
evident that in the case of Silvio Dante
the concierge of the de mio crime family
and one of Tony's most trusted friends
and advisors in the penultimate episode
of the series the blue comets lupertazzi
boss phil leotardo is on a quest for
revenge and orders a series of
coordinated hits against the de mio
crime family for killing his brother and
sadly that's when Silvio is introduced
to a couple of bullets Silvio and Patsy
Parisi are driving away from the
bada-bing when two men opened fire Patsy
starts shooting back and manages to
escape but Sylvia is hit several times
and his wounds land him in an intensive
care unit in the series finale
made-in-america is revealed that Silvio
is comatose as a result of his wounds
and the doctors don't expect him to wake
up he spends the fun'll episode of the
series on life supports remember this it
will also be important later one of the
most debated and controversial scenes in
Sopranos history or maybe even TV
history starts when Tony and his family
meet up for dinner Tony plays journey's
don't stop believin on the restaurant
jukebox and as the four members of the
soprano family show up for a meal the
tension becomes more and more unbearable
we move from shady looking guys in the
restaurant to Meadow
struggling to park a car outside then
just as his daughter seems to be walking
in the restaurants Tony looks up on the
screen cuts the black so what happened
well there are two basic interpretations
- let's start with the most optimistic
let's believe the cut to black is simply
a last moment with Tony Soprano and we
can see that his future will be full of
tension and uncertainty
yeah the Ganga warmers weren't his kids
seem happy and he's settling in for a
quiet meal the bad guy at the counter is
Shady anything could have happened to
meadow out on the streets and Tony us a
look up every time the bell over the
restaurants door rings because he has to
be sure he's not being ambushed Tony's
alive but he's never safe if he survives
the series he's going to spend the rest
of his days fearing for his life and
that final scene was simply a connection
to him being closed off forever
sure maybe Tony Soprano made it out of
the show alive but as possible that Tony
had his brains blown out on that diner
it's entirely valid to believe that the
screen cuts to black because thus the
moments where Tony dies the sudden cut
is his point of view as a character but
the sudden darkness showing that his
life has come to an end there's actually
some evidence backing up this
interpretation as Tony's possible death
was foreshadowed earlier in the show in
the season 6 episode soprano home movies
Bobby back eolleri and Tony are chatting
about the nature of death when Bobby
theorizes a death is simple and quick
yeah our line of work you probably don't
even hear it when it happens this little
line strongly suggests that in Tony's
last moments he didn't hear the bullet
that laid him low or even realize he was
about to die
maybe the shady guy in the jacket went
to the bathroom to pick up a gun Allah
the Godfather came back out and shot
Tony in the head we didn't see it
because neither did Tony and it's
possible that one of the greatest
characters in TV history was left for
dead in that New Jersey diner so which
is it is Tony Soprano alive or dead
after the final shot
series creator David Chase has always
remained famousy cagey about explaining
the scene and shortly after the last
episode aired he insisted that no one
was trying to be audacious with the
final moments Chase has been asked
several more times to reflect on the
ending in the years since a series
finale and each time he's remained
relatively ambiguous and his explanation
he's admitted that his original
intention was to kill Tony off at the
end but he changed his mind and went
with the sudden cuts of black instead he
explained simply I thought it was more
interesting maybe the best explanation
for the scene from the writers has come
from Sopranos writer
Terence winter my interpretation was
that when you're Tony's
chrono even going out for ice cream with
your family is fraught with paranoia
he's sown a life of murder mayhem and
treachery and everybody who walks in a
guy in a Members Only jacket this could
be the guy well that could be the guy
you're always looking over your shoulder
and at some point whether it happened
that night or not when you lived that
life one day somebody's going to walk
out of a men's room and that's it for
you when it comes to a story's ending
there are two ways to take things
literally and symbolically so literally
whether you believe Bobby baccalieri is
lying about never hearing death coming
or not we have a definitive answer for
Tony Soprano he does not die we know
this because he's still alive when the
screen cuts to black ending explains
that Tony's alive you're welcome
thank you thank you symbolically however
things are obviously a lot more
complicated as we're going you didn't
get sick but you don't need a talking
face to find a potent symbol in The
Sopranos the events of the last two
episodes actually hinted a definitive
explanation we see in that episode that
dr. Melfi ends her relationship with
Tony while Sylvia was shot and lingers
in a coma neither alive nor dead the
first episode of the series begins of
Tony meeting dr. Melfi while the
second-to-last episode shows that
working relationship coming to an end so
if the show is the story of Tony and
Melfi sessions the story concludes once
those sessions conclude - it doesn't
seem like a coincidence at the same
episode feature Silvio being shot which
leads to him being rendered comatose a
state in which he's technically alive
but for all intents and purposes he's
not its ovios komamura's Tony's end in
the final episode
he may be breathing but he's seemingly
in a space between life and death
already so whether the final episodes
cut to black as a bullet and Tony skull
or a symbol that his life's actual
journey has come to an end is pretty
much irrelevant as long as he pursues
his worst impulses and stays in his life
of crime he's as good as dead every
minute of the day check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos but your favorite TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the Val so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]